Faster than might seem appropriate
and faster than I wish.
We've
come to the succession crisis.
I wish we had another week to three weeks,
but we don't
martyrdom.
What does a martyr term we hear
all over the place now there are
martyrs of this cause and
martyrs of that cause.
John Brown was a martyr.
Yeah.
The most important thing about John Brown
is I tried to say the other day and I
want to conclude with
several comments about that.
Now
he's in how he died and in
the aftermath of his death.
United States was a Christian country.
Europe was essentially a
Christian civilization.
John Brown would be filtered through
a Christian imagination either way,
whether people came to admire and sort
of agonizingly love him or agonizingly
hate him.
John Brown's raid on Harper's ferry was
all his own, said Frederick Douglass.
His zeal in the cause of freedom
was infinitely superior to mine.
Mine was a taper light.
His was the burning sun.
Mine was bounded by time.
His stretched away to the
silent shores of eternity.
I could speak for the slave.
John Brown could fight for the slave.
I could live for the slave.
John Brown could die for the slave.
There's a clarity and that among the
many you logistic statements about John
Brown and the many of the
Frederick Douglass himself.
May Douglas you'll remember had great
ambivalence about this man and chose not
to join him on the rate at Harper's ferry.
I Brown was captured in the raid.
Raid only lasted 48 hours.
It was in some ways the
military strategic blunder.
He was taken to a jail,
a four miles from Harper's ferry,
Charles Town Virginia,
now West Virginia,
and he would reside there
for about the next six weeks,
six
in that period,
he would be put on trial
and the most celebrated trial.
To that point in American history,
there were three charges,
all of which were punishable by death,
at least in Virginia,
treason against the United States.
It was considered treason
to attack a federal arsenal.
I suppose it's still would be,
although
we don't try too many
people for treason anymore
to inciting a slave insurrection.
Pretty serious crime and Virginia
and third from Mara for murder.
Okay.
Trial began on the 27th of October.
It lasted three and a half days.
State of Virginia famously tried to
provide a lawyer for John Brown and Brown
refused that states supplied lawyer.
He laid on a cot because of his injuries
and his wounds and the courtroom,
this would be drawn and put it up in
lithographs and pictures all over the
country.
He was eventually defended in
court by three northerners,
uh,
lawyers who came down to help
closing arguments for the 31st of October,
the jury deliberated 45 minutes,
returned a verdict of guilty on all three
counts and it was announced he would
be hung a about a month
later on December 2nd,
from November 2nd to
December 2nd that one month,
November 2nd was the last day in
court where they sentenced him.
Okay.
He had one month in jail.
He apparently went over as a jailer who
found John Brown and one of the most
fascinating characters you'd ever seen.
People came from the north and we're
allowed to visit him, including his wife
from jail.
He wrote approximately 100 letters
all over the country to newspapers,
to editors, to magazines,
to members of his family,
particularly to his wife.
He was writing his own epitaph.
He was creating his own romantic legend.
He was arguing his own case.
He, of course, had pled innocent.
Okay.
Are many of those letters.
I had the great privilege to read a
whole batch of the originals once,
how's did of all places,
the Pennsylvania historical society.
He wrote this one to his wife,
which may be indicative of Brown's vision
of his own ax and a vision that was
now going to stick in some
ways in poetry and in song.
I have been whipped,
he wrote to his wife as the saying goes,
but I'm sure I can recover all the last
capital occasioned by that disaster by
only hanging a few minutes by the neck.
And I feel quite determined to make
the utmost possible out of my defeat.
Uh, I love you dear, but
I can't wait to hang.
Okay,
John Brown,
it was a troubled man. He was morbid
man. He was an old testament man,
but he probably was not crazy as
so many people said at the time,
people have said,
ever since
is altruism on behalf of black
people was not utterly selfless,
but he was an extraordinary example
of an American or white
American, uh, who, uh,
put his money where his mouth was.
He didn't have any money,
but his life for his mouth was
and took it into the south.
Now he was executed,
hung out in a field outside
of Charlestown, Virginia,
guarded by some 3000 American troops.
Um, there were all kinds of fears of
attempts to break him out and season by
northern Yankee bands.
There were all kinds of threats
of escape plans in the newspapers.
And by the way, one of the most startling
things about the John Brown story,
once it broke and had never been a
sensation quite like this in American
newspapers,
here was the south oldest greatest,
worst fear and abolitionists from the
north with a band of men and a bunch of
weapons invading the south and
trying to incite slave insurrection.
They'd been kind of
predicting this all along.
Oh and behold it happened in a trunk of
stuff back at the farm in Maryland that
he had rented for several months whereas
men had gathered after his capture.
Yeah,
it was found a whole
stash of letters and maps.
The old man had kept all
kinds of maps of the south.
He had maps of sections of Alabama,
Georgia.
He even had extra certain towns
on those maps. I don't know,
the old guide is like maps maybe just
stayed up at night kind of plan with his
maps like some of us do with our rand
McNally maps when we want to wish our
selves out of where we are.
But when these maps were
found in the press got hold
of these all over the south,
these stories spread and local newspapers
for 20 stories about the maps of their
county or their section of a state.
There was hysteria.
Uh,
northern teachers working in the south
were tarred and feathered and I turned
her a piano tuner in
Tennessee was lynched.
Okay.
Cause he was from Massachusetts.
Fear set in across the south that
they were going to be other abolition
emissaries. That was always
the term used and there were,
there were predictions and threats of
all kinds, especially in South Carolina.
Okay.
John Brown, when when you, and he did read
some of these newspapers, must've smile.
Nope.
He was hung.
His body was delivered to his wife.
It traveled all the way by train all
the way up to know upstate New York to
North Alabama, New York,
where he was buried
aside in a very remote place, I
must say, in upstate New York,
they have a gathering there every year
of something called the John Brown
society.
It's run by a bunch of people from New
York City and they have an annual speaker
and an annual pilgrimage
to old John Brown's grave.
And I had the privilege of one year of
giving that lecture and the courthouse,
whereas body had laid in state.
It was interesting to meet the erstwhile
folks at the John Brown society who are
strange and interesting
lot and I can assure you,
yeah,
but it's an isolated place.
Yeah.
But pilgrimage,
pilgrimages already started happening,
especially among African Americans
in the north to that remote site.
Okay.
Right in the wake of his burial.
The most important thing about John
Brown's raid and John Brown was the
aftermath.
It's what people made of it
in the north.
Certain members of that secret six so
called of white abolitionists to ad served
him and helped him and raise money
for him and wrote letters with him,
fled the country,
some to Canada,
Frederick Douglass himself.
And there were letters discovered
between Douglas and John Brown.
Okay.
Uh, himself will flee the country, uh,
out of Rochester,
New York,
across Lake Erie and to Canada and out
the Saint Lawrence River to England
because of
fear of his arrest. And there was a
warrant put out for Frederick Douglas.
Douglas is arrest and a federal
marshal arrived in Rochester, York.
Only about a day after Douglas left town
intellectuals and poets and writers and
the press throw in Whittier and Emerson
all over the north and in England and
in France began to try their hand at the
meaning of John Brown as Christian hero,
as martyr of a cars,
as a man who would do that,
which the rest of them
would not have done.
And I want to suggest, I'm going
to give you really for arguments,
just try them on or
why John Brown matters.
Why you matter then and why you still
matters in any discussion we have in
American society about what
constitutes terrorism now,
what constitutes revolutionary
violence when is a cause?
So just that the means justify the ends.
When is violence in a
moral cause justified?
Is it ever justified? Go answer
those questions in an ethics course.
Go answer those questions
in a politics course.
Go answer those questions in a history
course and you have one of the hardest
questions of wall was John Brown,
a midnight terrorist
or revolutionary hero.
John Brown is a very troubling legacy.
Nobody should pretty fine and
nobody should totally dismissing.
I'd say he leaves us with four essential
questions and you can add to this or if
you want first,
he really makes his face this
question of the meaning of martyrdom.
What is a martyr?
How do we define a martyr?
What constitutes the value?
Is there elements of martyrdom
to
how do we deal with revolutionary
violence in history or today?
One kind of Cosby just as I
just said earlier, so just,
yeah,
that violence in its
name is somehow justified
three and here I'm going to
give you a list within the list.
I think John Brown is our
template in American history.
There are others you could point to the
leaders of the Hay market riot, the,
there, there are many other cases, um,
in our history of people who acted
in a cause and used violence.
But John Brown,
um,
forces us to face the almost
natural ambivalences about his ax.
He is disturbing and inspiring.
Note all these opposites.
He in some ways worked
for the highest ideals,
human freedom and the idea of equality.
But it also uses the most ruthless deeds.
There's a certain majesty about his
character, at least in the aftermath,
but there's also a lot of folly.
He was a monster to some to others. He's,
he's a saint. He's a warrior. St
He killed for justice.
Yes.
When does that work for you?
He was a great example of what
had been brewing all over the,
the culture by the 1850s.
We've talked about this over and over
of this struggle between human law,
law,
fashion and congress,
law facet and fashion by people
and the so called higher law.
When do you abide by a higher law
than the laws of your society?
When is it just a break human
law in the name of higher law?
Who Decides?
And lastly,
I think he's one of those Avengers
of history who do the work.
Other people won't,
can't or shouldn't.
Okay.
Men consented to his death,
said Frederick Douglass and one of
those eulogy speech was much later.
The speech is much later in 1880 men
consented to his death and then when home
and taught their children
to honor his memory.
And then fourth, and the last question
that's always laying out there,
John Brown was a white man who killed
white people to free black people.
And that's actually one
of his deepest legacies.
In my first years of teaching a bigger
term in highschool and Flint, Michigan,
I taught lots of young black people
who thought John Brown was black.
They had been taught that he was black.
Sometimes in churches,
there's a church in Springfield,
Massachusetts, the John
Brown went to, attended.
They say he was a member.
It's called the John Brown church.
There's some people there. You still
have to convince that it was white.
Does it matter?
Why does it matter?
Why is John Brown's and been such a
romantic hero in black culture and poetry
and painting and song?
Yeah.
Michael Harper,
the great modern African American poet
has a little line on,
one of his poems is called the
poem is called history and Brown.
The line is come to the crusade,
not as Negroes,
but as brothers like brother Brown.
Well,
you can try all those questions on and
if you come up with some perfect answers,
do let me know.
But before we leave John Brown,
I want to leave you with my favorite
passage ever written about the meaning and
memory of John Brown.
And
you can see if it fits or not.
It's in a speech by WB Dubois,
greatest black scholar
writer of the 20th century.
Dubois gave a speech about John
Brown at Harper's ferry in 1932
they were dedicating a plaque memorial.
Uh,
this has been done before,
but they were dedicating and yet another
sort of John Brown marker at Harper's
ferry,
and the ending of that speech,
I think is the most poignant thing
anybody ever said about John Brown,
and it's why he's so troubling.
This is dubois is ending.
Some people have the idea that crucifixion
consists in the punishment of an
innocent man.
The essence of crucifixion is
that men are killing a criminal,
that men have got to kill him,
and yet that the act of crucifying
him is the salvation of the world.
John Brown broke the law.
He killed human beings.
Those people who defended slavery
had had to execute John Brown,
although they knew that in killing him,
they were committing the greater crime.
It is out of that human paradox
that there comes any crucifixion.
Okay,
good morning
sermon is over.
I've named my text.
Now let's do some history.
Okay.
The raid on Harper's ferry and the
execution of John Brown of course, came.
Whoops.
There we are
on the eve of an extremely pivotal
American election to say the least.
You all know the Republican party had a
good showing in 1856 and nearly won it's
first time out.
Now,
what will this Republican Party be by
1860 how will it threaten the south? Well,
it's threatened the south John Bronze,
right on Harper's vera in
his execution or a template
all into that next spring
as the American political culture held
it's conventions and nominated candidates
and prepared for an election
that now people said,
my decide whether the union
would hold together or not.
The Democrats held their
convention in late April,
early May in the worst possible
place they can hold it.
They had scheduled it well ahead of
time in Charleston, South Carolina.
Charleston was a hotbed of southern
rites and southern nationalism,
if you want to call it that,
and southern secessionism already.
It was
now the the can to the front running
candidate of the Democratic Party by 1860
and this man had been working for this
for a decade and a half. It was of course,
Stephen Douglas of Illinois.
Same Stephen Douglas of
popular sovereignty fame,
but Stephen Douglas had
made one a slip up. Oh,
he made more than one,
but he might one or two really big
slipups in terms of his fellow southern
Democrats, I mean is by far the most
prestigious person in their party.
But in one of his debates
with Abraham Lincoln,
one of those incredible debates with
Lincoln, the one in Freeport, Illinois,
and much ado was made about this.
It was almost a throwaway line,
although it wasn't thrown away.
Yeah.
Lincoln pushed Douglas and he said,
do you mean then judge Douglas?
Is he always called?
He would never call him senator.
Judge Douglas.
Do you mean then that if the people who
settle the Western territory pop your
popular sovereignty business,
what does that,
that really means the folks
can vote it out, right?
In spite of what the
dred Scott Decision says,
dred Scott decision just said that
because of the Fifth Amendment,
you cannot stop a person taking his slaves
anywhere he wants. And Lincoln says,
but, but judge, what's that done
to your popular sovereignty,
Douglas as well?
That people can still vote?
And if the people vote slavery
out and they voted out.
Okay.
And his fellow southern
Democrats immediately started
writing to him and wiring
him and saying, wait a minute, Steven,
did we live in the land of the
dred Scott decision or not?
It became known to southern Democrats
as the so called free port. Doctor
and Douglas kept trying to
dance around it, avoid it
in opposition to so called Freeport
doctrine and in opposition to Douglas at
this southern Democrat at
the, at the Democratic Party
convention, and by the way,
that Democratic Party is by
anyone with his eyes open.
The only truly national
political party left in America,
the hope of saving the union,
just in a political sense,
by 1860 was with the Democrats.
This Republican Party is resumed to see
was a northern party almost exclusively
countering the Douglas southern Democrats,
led by none other than Jefferson Davis,
a senator from Mississippi at that point,
a long distinguished member of Congress,
secretary of war,
coming on a west point and so on.
They came up with what they now call
a slave code for the territory's.
That's what they called it.
And that slave code for the territory's
was now to be a protection in the
constitution and explicit protection
in the constitution of slave ownership
anywhere in the western
territories of the United States.
They wanted, in essence, not just the
dred Scott Decision Supreme Court case,
they wanted a federal gay.
They wanted not just the repeal
of the Kansas Nebraska Act,
geographical division, not just
the dred Scott Case, which said,
prisoners, right, take
slaves anywhere. They wish.
They wanted a explicit federal guarantee
of the right to slave ownership and he
wanted it to be a constitutional
amendment if necessary.
Now,
this is why the Democratic Party
toward self apart at Charleston,
they had a two thirds rule.
So even though Stephen Douglas did
muster a small majority of support in the
first balloting, he could not win
the nomination. And when Douglas,
his supporters managed to pass a platform
without the so called slave code for the
territory's southern delegates of eight
states, they'd all prepared for
this stocked out of the convention.
The convention ended.
They nominated nobody
and they split into two parties,
the southern Democrats and
the northern Democrats.
And everybody knows that
when a party does this,
it almost guarantees that we'll lose.
And
it did
the southern Democrats re to
reconvene in Baltimore and June 18
and um,
I'm sorry,
the northern Democrats reconvened the
so called official Democratic Party.
We convene to Baltimore and June 18
they nominated a Stephen Douglas.
No surprise. They called
themselves the National Democrats,
the southern Democrats of those eight
southern states. It's the deep south.
Yeah.
Met in Richmond,
Virginia.
Shortly after that and nominated John See
Breckenridge of Kentucky slave holder,
but a moderate known to be some
kind of an old Henry Clay moderate.
Although he'd never been a wig.
Okay.
To be their candidate for president.
And by the end of June,
1860,
the democratic party had to
two candidates, Breckenridge,
southern Democrat Douglas,
the northern Democrats.
Now the Republican Party had
its convention in Chicago.
There's an extraordinary convention.
It had never been one quite
like it in American history.
It was Rawkus.
They would just parades and
waves of people sometimes hired,
sometimes induced den by lots of drink
to come into the so called a Wigwam,
which was this big convention hall of
a kind they had constructed in Chicago.
It was sometimes called the shouters
convention because these people were sort
of hired to shout for one
candidate or the other.
What fun and nonsense it must have been.
Yeah.
The leading Canada, the Republicans
of course was William h Seward,
sort of New York,
longterm time senator from New York had
strong antislavery credentials as a good
solid free soiler and indeed even
had fairly strong abolitionist ties.
Okay.
And He'd been there at the creation of
the Republican Party and he had a kind of
a machine.
I have a sword,
but there was this strange insurgency
out of Illinois behind a favorite son
named Abraham Lincoln,
and wasn't all that well known,
even though he had become fairly well
known in his run against Stephen Douglas
and 1858 but of course he'd lost that
election narrowly to Douglas and 58 he
doesn't one term in the u s house back
in the late 1840 [inaudible] during the
Mexican war.
And then he lost on is tempted
reelection two years in the House of
Representatives,
or rather inexperienced.
But it turns out brilliant politician,
the platform of the Republican Party,
which was very important these years,
people were reading platforms, believe
it or today, platforms SMAPP forms,
right?
Southerners were really reading the dumb,
the Republican party platform.
The platform of 1860 was a little broader
and had somewhat more moderate appeals
in it then they're 1856 deeply
free soil platform had had,
they made big appeals in 1860,
uh,
to create higher federal tariffs to
create free homestead law in the West.
These are all appeals. You know, the,
the common man and to the
rights of immigrants because
the Republicans were now
successful by the late 1850s at all,
but desolving that native as party,
the know nothings or the
American party and we're drawing.
Most native is not quite all,
but most native is into
the Republican Party and,
and they'd manage this strange marriage
of a kind of a pro immigrant platform.
At the same time,
they're attracting nativist who are as
worried about slavery as they were about
Catholics.
They appealed to a certain
anti southern feeling.
There's no question about that.
Now Lincoln got the
nomination largely because in,
well one the convention was held in his
home state to William made Seward had
made a fair number of enemies
around the Republican coalition.
He was in the limelight
too long in a sense.
You could argue politically and Ilana
Republicans were looking for a candidate
who seemed more moderate
than that is Seward.
They wanted to run in this election in
a way that, you know, the upper south,
maybe the border states would actually
support them. And this Lincoln,
yeah, man. After all. He was
born in Kentucky, you know,
he's the kind of a border state guy
himself. Seward's just a Yankee.
So there's a certain irony and the
Lincoln got some support because he wasn't
seen as abolitionists.
Now that isn't necessarily as true.
Lincoln was on record all over the place
saying such things as he had an 1859 I
quote him,
Republicans believe that slavery is wrong
and they insist and we'll continue to
insist upon a national policy
which recognizes it and
deals with it as a wrong.
There can be no letting down on
this
reasonably clear language.
Oh dear,
I got to move him.
Sorry.
There you are.
Does Matthew Brady's famous photographs
that he took on the day of Abraham
Lincoln's Cooper Union speech in New York.
The speech,
the introduced Lincoln to the east and
according to Harold Holter and a reason
book made Lincoln President.
Now it's a bit overstated,
but ms pre beer didn't grow
the beard of the next year,
but the crisis was so serious now.
Well,
this northern antislavery free soil
Republican Party to democratic parties,
one southern one northern
splitting themselves
that are a group of American politicos
got together practically overnight late
that summer, 1860 and decided
to run yet a fourth candidate.
His name was John Bell of Tennessee
and they called themselves the
Constitutional Union party.
They drew together some old Whigs.
The Whig party doesn't exist anymore.
There's still some old Whigs
looking for a political home.
Yeah.
They drew some nativists and no nothings
and they drew border state people who
were just frightened of how this mess was
possibly gonna destroy the union.
Their platform was extremely simple.
They pledged themselves simply to quote,
defense of the Union and
enforcement of the law. Oh,
it could be against that.
They were for the Union and law,
both nice things
and almost unbelievably this party
had quite a few followers overnight.
Yeah,
no. When the election came, and I'll go
back to the map if you forgive me. Um,
okay.
It's worth looking at some quick numbers,
more than worth it.
This is one of the great for way races
for the presidency in American history.
We've only had really one
or two other four ways.
1912 was a four way.
Of course that guarantees almost you're
going to have a minority president that
is the one who wins,
is not going to win a majority,
and that's exactly what happened
in this case. Now, Abraham Lincoln,
the Republican was not even on
the ballot in 10 slave states.
Republicans weren't even put it on
the ballot in all of the deep south.
Okay.
Lincoln carried all of the northern
states and all of their electoral votes
except three in New Jersey.
Breckenridge,
the southern Democrat carried all the
slave states except parts of the Upper
South Virginia, Kentucky,
Tennessee, and Missouri.
Oh,
well you can see that on that map.
John Bell,
the Constitutional Union Canada,
there's overnight party that just said,
please save the Union. Whatever it takes.
We needed a new national compromise.
Bell Won Virginia, Kentucky,
and Tennessee. Upper south.
Okay.
Stephen Douglas,
who'd been kind of running for
president in his heart for 15 years.
One only one state,
Missouri.
Lincoln received only 26,000 votes
in the south in all the slave states.
He received only about 40%
of the total raw vote.
60% of Americans who voted in 1860 and
they voted in huge percentage is 75 80%
turnout.
60% of all those who voted did
not vote for Abraham Lincoln,
but he was elected.
And now of course the question
was what would the south to do?
What all this rhetoric about southern
unity and the possibility of of
succession,
uh, sorry. Oops.
I hope that work
colors aren't great or anything.
Well,
this is session crisis is an unprecedented
moment in American history and
happily we haven't quite had it since.
There were always rumors of Texas wanting
to succeed and the upper peninsula of
Michigan wanting to secede,
but nobody quite does a session anymore.
We got a lot of states rights going on,
but we don't necessarily do succession.
Would the south really do it now?
Lincoln made one thing
clear within his party.
He made almost no public appearances
after the election of 1860 into that
winter. Inaugurations were not held
in the 19th century until March.
As you may know, the interregnum
was a long time, four months,
four or five months.
This was the succession winter of 1860
61 but he made one thing very clear
within his party circles and his quote
after quote about this in private
correspondence.
He said,
whatever the south does that he wanted
the Republican Party to stand absolutely
firm on one thing and that was opposition
at all costs to the expansion of
slavery into the West.
He said that was their reason to be.
That was why they came into existence.
That is what they had been arguing for
six years and they would not give up that
line as he put it
on December 20th, 1860 South
Carolina Helda secession convention
December 20th and voted unanimously
to secede from the union.
They said in that act that they were
quote not in rebellion against the United
States.
They said they were only exercising
their sovereign power as a state to
withdraw.
They rooted there succession as they
had always rooted state sovereignty and
states' rights positions in the old
notion of a compact theory of government
that which a state chooses to
join in a central government.
It shall have the right
end power to withdraw from.
But the question now is would
anybody join them? Oh and by the way,
they declared themselves the
Paul Meadow Metal Republic,
but would anybody join South Carolina?
And this is where your book by Charles Do,
parcels of disunion comes
right into play here.
That wonderfully short and I think quite
brilliant treatment of these succession
commissioners is South Carolina was
the first date to send out succession
commissioners and other states in
the deep south and basically say,
please join us,
were hanging out on this limb.
It's scary out here and here are
the reasons you should join us.
The next state to go though,
it wasn't until the 9th of January
of [inaudible] 61 it was Mississippi.
Yeah.
Zippy held the secession convention and
then several deep South states fell like
dominoes.
Next Day,
January 10 Florida succeeded
Alabama on January 11th Georgia.
I want to come back to Georgia.
And just a second,
cause it's in a very interesting case.
George,
on January 19th in a very divided vote,
Louisiana in January 26 and Texas
on February 1st by February 1st,
1861 the seven states of the deep South,
South Carolina, Georgia, Florida, Alabama,
Mississippi, Louisiana and Texas
had seceded from the union.
They declared themselves the
confederate states of America.
They met at their first declared capitol
of Montgomery, Alabama. And they,
in effect a pointed,
there was no general election.
At first they appointed
the representatives or the
states appointed Jefferson
Davis of Mississippi,
Mississippi as their president.
Okay.
By the time Lincoln would take office
and first week in March and deliver his
first inaugural seven states in the
deep south had formed a new government.
Now
why did they do it?
I'm going to have to leave you a,
we have about seven, eight minutes,
which is great.
Um,
I want to focus briefly on Georgia to
show you the succession was no simple
process and many of these states
and it was great division,
which we will see later kind of come out
of its shell in the midst of a war and
some extent afterwards in reconstruction.
And I don't want to at least leave you
today with some explanations of why is
the session happened, interpretations
we've developed over the years
of why the south seceding
I may have to leave you hanging as to
just what happened to the rest of the
south and so on.
But the opera south doesn't budge
and are many reasons for that.
Virginia, North Carolina, Tennessee,
Kentucky, Arkansas and so on. Maryland,
there are many reasons for that.
It was somewhat less strong
attachment to slavery, uh,
in many of these regions,
especially in the mountain regions are
much more closer economic ties to the
north that now caused a whole variety
of fears are what's going to happen if
there's conflict or two countries or war.
Yeah,
fear that the war would actually
happen if there was war on their soil.
Okay.
You're not, you didn't have to
be too bright to figure that out.
And many people in the upper south,
some of whom have actually voted for,
for Bell and the Constitutional Union
party still had faith that somehow America
would reach a compromise.
Yeah.
That the party system would somehow
work this through. This was,
this was a very difficult patch,
you know,
but they work at this room
and there was a spirit,
especially in the upper south at
first and some of this in Georgia to,
to wait for 64,
wait four years.
I let this Lincoln Republican Party
have its way for a while. We'll see.
We, they would say, still have
a majority on the supreme court.
Okay.
Now, um, explanations.
Now Georgia can't, we can't, we can't,
we can't leave Georgia because
Georgia succession votes fascinating.
And that's what this map
in some ways shows you,
I don't know if you
can see this very well,
but the darker greenish color up there
is that green to you or blue and the rest
is kind of a puke yellow.
Um,
those bluish greenish regions are the
regions that tended to be against the
session there.
The regions that had
the least slavery there,
the mountainous regions
or the upland regions.
And we've now had detailed studies
of succession done in state by state,
especially in in, in Georgia
and North Carolina, Alabama.
Other places that show us that by far
the highest support for succession
was in those counties or those regions
with the largest numbers of slaves.
And this is where Charles do fits right
in. Read them closely. What are those?
The session commissioners arguing when
they go from Alabama up to Tennessee to
try to convince the Tennessee legislature
or the South Carolina Succession
Commissioner going to Virginia and
sitting down in the Virginia State House,
the Virginia legislature and arguing
with these people, come join us.
Come join us. What are they arguing?
And he's got document after document.
They're arguing for the preservation of
white security of white supremacy there
arguing for the preservation
of a slave economy.
They're arguing for the preservation of
white political supremacy there arguing
for resistance again,
and he's against any semblance of
those Republicans in the north.
May May somehow represent
about racial equality.
They're arguing for the preservation
of a slave labor system.
Put simply, there are no for the
preservation of a slave society.
Okay.
What's the session about slavery
read Charles.
Do.
All right. And the three minutes I have,
let me leave you with some arguments.
Why does south succeed,
oops,
sorry.
One
is what? Um, we might simply call, uh,
what I've just argued,
the preservation of a slave society,
the preservation of a slave system,
the preservation of a certain kind of
racial control over a society that they
now greatly feared would be threatened.
And this is in part what happened in
Georgia in their divided vote because in
Georgia, the upper counties
of Georgia, those more hilly,
mountainous regions of north
Georgia voted against the session,
the vote on succession and
Georgia on January 19th,
1861 was one 66 to one 30 130 of those
people who were elected to go to the
Georgia secession convention
is delegates voted against it.
And here was the theory that was at stake.
It was really an argument between
waiting til 64 or the argument used by
southern slave holders now,
but people from south Georgia
and all over the deep south,
it was the theory of a shrinking south.
And I really do believe this is one of
the most compelling arguments they had
about succession.
And it's why they were able to muster
enough folks to go with them in their
revolution.
The theory of a shrinking south was
the idea that if the Republicans gained
control of the federal
government through patronage,
through nominations to the Supreme Court,
through the much higher numbers they
had in the House of Representatives,
and even now with California and so on,
maybe even in the u s senate,
that eventually, and if they close off
the expansion of slavery in the West,
what does that do?
It cordons off and it contains,
and it begins to smother southern
society and the slave system.
And the theory wasn't on the rim of
the south. In Kentucky, in Missouri,
in Maryland, the price of
slaves would begin to dwindle.
Yeah.
And then what do people do when
the price of something goes down?
They sell it off, where are they going
to sell those slaves can't sell him west,
can't sell them to the Caribbean.
International slave trades illegal.
They're going to sell them into
the deep south. What happens?
The deep south becomes more and
more and more rather quickly,
a pressure cooker of increasingly
large numbers of slaves.
Okay.
And no place to expand to
prices as slaves would
continue to go down.
The value of their most precious asset.
Was it stake as was their security?
Their safety.
Okay.
Second reason, and I'm going to run out
of time any minute, I know what I mean.
Let me just lay these out.
I'm going to name them and I'm
going to leave you dangling here.
Uh,
the second is what I will
call the fear thesis.
The third is what I will
call southern nationalism.
The fourth is what I
will call agrarianism.
And the fifth is what I
will call the honor thesis.
I will resume that argument,
uh, when we resume next time.
But let me leave you with this.
Lincoln does get inaugurated of course,
in the midst of this,
yeah.
Inherits a nation divided
at the end of his first inaugural
speech comes those famous words.
Lincoln was of course capable of leaving
passages for us to quote and almost
everything he delivered in
almost everything that he wrote,
but he went to a little Shakespeare
at the end of his first inaugural.
By the way, at first,
inaugural was an olive branch.
We will never touch slavery
where it already exists.
We only intend to stop its expansion.
You are our brothers.
You are our countrymen.
Come back, do not leave us
members of a country.
He said, cannot divorce.
Used a divorce metaphor and then
he ended with I am Lowe's to close.
We're not enemies, but friends.
We must not be enemies.
Though passion may have strained.
It must not break our bonds of affection,
the mystic chords of memory,
stretching from every battlefield and
patriot to every living heart well yet
swell.
The chorus of the Union when again touched
is surely they will be by the better
angels of our nature.
That was beautiful poetry
and wishful thinking
because in the wake of his nomination,
his inauguration,
and eventually in the wake of Fort Sumpter
for more southern states are going to
join the deep south.
And I'll pick up that explanation.
Why next time.
Okay.